[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Robin Cresswell an associate
professor of comparative literature at
Yale he studies modern Arabic literature
the practice of literary translation art
and revolution and modernist poetry in
French English and Spanish and Arabic
his writings have appeared in The New
Yorker the New York Review of Books and
Harper's Magazine
among many other publications today
we'll talk with professor Cresswell
about his new book city of beginnings
poetic modernism and Beirut for which he
was recently awarded the Macmillan
Center's Gatiss Smith International Book
Prize for best first book
welcome professor kress well it's a
pleasure to be here let's start with an
overview of your book tell us about it
so the book is a study of a modernist
movement the modernist movement in
Arabic poetry which is a movement that
happens in Beirut the capital of Lebanon
between the end of World War 2 and about
1975 when the Civil War begins in
Lebanon and I think one could make the
argument I would make the argument that
this is really the most important most
influential artistic movement in the
Arab world since World War two I think
that the poets of this movement really
fundamentally changed the understanding
of what poetry is what its audience is
how it relates to that audience and how
it relates to its classical past as well
as how it fits into the wider landscape
of modern poetry in the world so it's a
it's a to look at that movement in
particular and I focus on the work of
poets like Denise who is a serial
Lebanese poet who is still alive
a man named Youssef el cow who was an
editor of the magazine that I focus on
and some other poets and critics as well
it's also a book about it's about
Lebanon during this period and Beirut in
particular when Lebanon really occupies
a slightly anomalous or unique position
in Arab intellectual landscape it's it's
the moment it's kind of the golden age
for Beirut when a lot of intellectuals
from Egypt Syria Iraq are fleeing from
an increasingly sort of monolithic
political culture in those places and
they come to Beirut which is kind of
overflowing with magazines and films
from abroad and has a very weak state
and therefore a very weak censorship and
so they have a sort of intellectual
freedom to to to work in this to
elaborate a kind of modernist movement
so it's a book about what modernism
means what artistic modernism means in
Beirut during its golden era I'm curious
what led you to write the book I know
you do study a lot of different kinds of
poetry but why this well in large part
it just had to do with my feeling that
this is really the most fascinating
artistic movement and and they produced
some great poetry and I mean it has to
do with a kind of feeling its aesthetic
feeling on my part that this is
wonderful poems and something that I
could imagine myself working on for you
know six or seven years and not getting
bored and continuing to learn so that
was the basis of it I also feel like
this obviously very important movement
while it's been quite well studied
insofar as any modern Arabic poetry has
been quite well studied has not been
helpfully placed in an international
context I mean these were poets who
really thought one of the things that
modernism means for them is a kind of
Cosmopolitan or internationalist outlook
on culture so the so the magazine that I
focus on which is
called shower magazine which means
poetry magazine which is the name that
they took from Harriet Monroe's little
magazine of the same name which is still
published in Chicago one of the things
that they thought modernity meant of
Hadassah in Arabic is an
internationalist outlook so this
magazine published an immense amount of
translations from particularly English
and French 20th century poetry but also
German poetry and Spanish poetry so
Whitman and Lorca and Octavio Paz and
Sancho paths and even fois and TS Eliot
and pound
so as an amazingly cosmopolitan sort of
group and so I try to take that fact
seriously and think about you know what
what what placing this movement this
very important Arabic movement in a much
wider intellectual context can help us
how it can help us understand that
movement and I also had the feeling that
I mean I work in a comparative
literature department and I feel like
this is a moment when compare attests
are beginning to understand that really
the comparative literature has not meant
has not had a very wide remit
historically speaking in terms of the
literature that looks at it's mostly
been looking at European and American
literature's and I think that by looking
at a movement which is so cosmopolitan
an internationalist and placing in that
sort of context
can also help comparative literature
studies kind of deeper ventral eyes
itself and see what it can learn by
looking at you know corpus a corpus of
literature that it really has been for
the most part neglected so in looking at
the poetry in Beirut how would you say
it compares to the other poetry that was
being done in the Middle East during
that time and then as well as in the
Western world what are some of the
similarities if there were any and
differences so the movement that I'm
looking at this modernist movement and
Beirut had a very antagonistic
relationship with poets and intellect
wills elsewhere in the region the region
meaning essentially three other major
intellectual capitals which would be
Cairo Damascus and Baghdad and so as I
say baby occupied a kind of unique place
within this geography broadly speaking I
would say poets and intellectuals in
those other countries Egypt Syria and
Iraq were struggling with how to think
about the relationship between
intellectuals and newly independent
post-colonial States they were for the
most part nationalist intellectuals of
one sort or another be a kind of local
nationalist Egyptian nationalism or
Iraqi nationalism or pan-arab
nationalism or they were Marxists and so
they thought that the relationship
between poetry or culture and politics
should be a very close one that they
were engaged a intellectuals and so the
notion of engagement which comes very
directly from south is a kind of
intellectual orthodoxy at this moment in
the 50s 60s and up into the 70s where
the poet views him or herself as being
engaged in political questions very
explicitly and so the post and I'm
looking at part of what they also meant
by modernism was not just a kind of
Cosmopolitan international outlook they
also insisted that poetry and politics
should have nothing to do with one
another that culture should be the space
of absolute freedom and questioning and
that the state in particular should have
no role in deciding or imposing itself
upon the intellectual class and so this
was the idea that you know poetry should
be self-sufficient or autonomous is I
think a kind of intellectual commonplace
of the post-world War two period outside
the Middle East especially in Europe and
America where basically this is of
course remember during the early Cold
War period American and allied
intellectuals in Europe
are basically making this argument that
you know what is the role of culture in
this moment well it has to be a space of
freedom it has to be free from state
control because we don't want to be like
those poets and intellectual workers in
the second world among in the Soviet
Union are its allies where the state
gets to decide what you ought to think
so that's those are the very broad
parameters I think of that Cold War
intellectual culture and in which these
Arab movements situate themselves okay
and what were some of these poets and
Beirut actually writing about was it
love was it death you know what were the
general topics that thing yes gate says
that there are only really two subjects
for poetry which are sex and death and I
think he's broadly speaking he's
probably right no they do they write
love poetry they write they do write a
lot of elegies actually I mean speaking
about death it's one of the things that
I look at in the book is the ways in
which they the tradition of the
gyeon-woo of elegy in Arabic is an
extremely old one it goes back to the
pre-islamic period and I have a chapter
in the book in particular about the way
that a Jenice understands the writing of
LED is one of the things he does that's
very odd is that he writes a lot of
elegies for classical poets that is to
say Arab poets who live in the 8th 9th
12th centuries what does it mean to
write analogy for somebody who's been
dead for a millennium or more and so
anyway what if one of the things that
I'm that I argue in that chapter is that
as opposed to the way we usually think
of elegiac poetry which is a poetry of
feelings of emotion really what he's
doing in those poems is kind of
constructing a genealogy of poets so by
by Elledge izing by mourning the death
of this long dead poet one of the things
that he's doing is trying to construct a
kind of a modernist in fact genealogy of
poets that stretch back into the
the early portions of the Arabic poetry
thereby suggesting that in fact Arabic
poetry has its own sort of modernist
stream that goes back for a very long
time then it's not merely this
contemporary sort of movement so they
write elegies they write a lot of love
poetry they write you a Deniz one of the
things another thing that I talk about
in the book he writes a lot of poems
that have to do with kind of travel an
itinerary that he keeps on obsessively
retracing from how he got from Damascus
to Beirut and what sort of meanings that
sort of journey had so they write about
the sorts of things that in one sense
poets have always written about but they
do it with a particular purpose okay and
how did you do the research for the book
and did you encounter any surprises or
things you didn't necessarily expect as
you were exploring the body of work so
most of the this is a literary but it's
for the most part literary criticism and
most of the research involved reading
old magazines and books of poetry I did
go to the library at the American
University in Beirut to look at some old
newspapers from the 40s and 50s I also
did go to the University of Chicago
Special Collections which has which is
where the archive of the Congress for
cultural freedom is housed the Congress
for cultural freedom was a front group
for the CIA for the American CIA which
during the immediate post-war period set
up a whole umbrella of highbrow literary
magazines among them the most famous one
being encounter in Britain but also and
just about any other country you can
imagine especially in Europe it was a
kind of Marshall plan for the
intellectual class so clove and demo not
and mundo nuevo they had this whole
network of magazines that they set up
and they also sponsored conferences all
over the world and this was their
attempt to kind of woo
at first European but then also Asian
African Middle Eastern intellectuals to
their way of thinking about cultural
freedom one of the conferences that they
set up a rather infamous conference at
least if you're interested in Arabic
poetry was was held in Rome in 1961 and
it was a conference about the modern
Arabic literature and them and world
literature in fact and all the poets
that I study were present at this
conference which was also which was
hosted by Stephen spender the the
British poet and Ignacio Salone the
famous Italian novelist and and this
conference has been kind of pointed to
by critics of the modernist group as
being proof that they were basically
supported by and in cahoots with the
Central Intelligence Agency no but
people did not know at the time of
course that it was being funded although
there were lots of rumors about it and
so this was a real accusations and
counter-accusations went back and forth
during the night all throughout the
1960s about whether or not this
modernist group in Beirut was actually a
kind of playing footsie with American
work imperialism so that was one of the
things I wanted to discover by going
back to this and it's a very interesting
and complicated story basically they for
for interesting reasons could not come
to this conference in Rome was a kind of
audition for the arab poets to say is
there some space for us to negotiate and
come to an agreement about publishing a
magazine and beirut in the end they did
not come to an agreement and they did
not they did not publish with that group
with
but the group that I'm that I'm
concerned with they did publish a
magazine was called how odd it was out
of Beirut but it was not it was not the
poet's that I'm looking at who really
ran that show so I I was able to however
find out that some of some early issues
of the magazine did receive funding from
the Congress for cultural freedom and
that was an that was unexpected mm-hmm
why do you think Beirut was at the
center of this modern poetry I don't
know if the word explosion would be
correct to use in this instance yeah
well I think that Beirut and lebanon in
general had a somewhat unusual
relationship to the whole concept or the
whole discourse on modernity and it was
a very it was a positive one i think
that the the intellectual class was in
general
somewhat like singapore a little bit
later they were open to modernity as a
kind of way of opening up the economy of
opening up artistic life to currents
from abroad to international styles of
thinking and it was very valued it was
so the poets that i'm looking at were in
some ways very very mainstream to
lebanese intellectual life even if they
were not so even if they were
antagonistically related to other
streams of arab life at the moment i
also think that as i as i mentioned
before the peculiarity of beirut is that
it had a very weak state this is for
historical reasons the french which was
the imperial power and lebanon what was
not yet called Lebanon during the
Mandate period between the wars
basically it was the it was the the
poorer of the two imperial powers
Britain and France in the region and it
ran the mandate on a kind of shoestring
budget
so it starved the state of a lot of
resources also Lebanon is a country with
lots of
different confessional groups and Druze
Maronite Christians Shias and Sunnis
Armenians and the leaders of those
communities were often happy not to have
the state take over things like
education and health services so they
were happy to also star of the state and
in some ways or keep it from becoming
very powerful so one of the knock-on
effects of this history is that as I
said censorship laws were relatively
below and so there was an emerging and
very lively civil society in the sense
that there were journals there were
newspapers and they fought with each
other they didn't tow the state's party
line even if they were towing one or the
other confessional groups party line
let's say so there was a kind of
effervescence to intellectual life
during this period that had to do with
the peculiar history of Lebanon itself
and poetry though was hugely popular
among all different classes of people
there in Lebanon yes which is somewhat
unusual compared to other countries I
would say even more broadly than that
that you know poetry is the oldest Arab
art form we have really I mean we have
poems from the pre-islamic period so
it's a it's a form with a with a
fourteen fifteen hundred year history
behind it and so it's a kind of the
queen of the arts and it has been so
that when the Arab Spring occurred in
2011 it was not terribly surprising that
the great slogan of that moment shot ud
despot the Nizam the people want the
downfall of the regime is actually taken
borrowed from adapted from a poem by a
Tunisian poet named Al Qasimi should be
because poetry has this tremendous aura
and status as both an art form with a
long history as well as contemporary
resonance as well as popular following
those
the other audience and that's something
that I think it takes a little while for
Americans to wrap their heads around
that this is that this is a form that
while it was I think entering into a
kind of moment of crisis after World War
two and and that crisis has continued it
is still a form which had great which
had great status and great great elite
literary status as well as a popular
audience and in some ways we can only
think about somebody like you know
Shakespeare enjoying in our own culture
when you're reading the poems I imagine
of course they're in Arabic yes what was
it like for you to and I obviously know
you read Arabic how was it like to think
about the poetry while written in Arabic
but translating it into English was that
very difficult yeah that's a great
question I mean it it's um I do a lot of
translating in the book because I do
close readings of poems and to do those
close readings when it has to have the
text there next to you and of course
you're writing your commentary in
English but you're writing about a poem
that has been written in Arabic so you
have to kind of signpost the translation
with with the Arabic words that you
might be talking about and it's very
tricky and you have to be very careful
about a choosey about which poems you're
going to look closely at because you
also I also want you know part of the
the stakes of the book I would say is to
persuade possibly skeptical American or
English language readers that this is a
great poetical tradition and it's
something that we can learn from and
it's interesting for us to read so I did
want to choose poems that I thought are
great poems that are interesting and
then also have something to say you know
that I can say clearly and cleanly about
the way the language works so I think
you have to be I think you just have to
be especially careful about what texts
you choose because you have to
be able to explain the enormous
intricacy of what's going on in the
Arabic in English right
and a lot of times there are some words
that there are simply no English words
for correct
you mean like untranslatable yes
I'm not a great fan of the idea of
untranslated bility I have to say I mean
I think that all words are in some ways
translatable there are certain words
that maybe need paraphrasing rather than
strict one-to-one sorts of
correspondence I mean that is true but I
don't think that translation is really
captured by the idea of substituting a
word in one language for a word in
another language I think really the
units of sense and aesthetic sense that
we're talking about when we talk about
doing translation are much broader than
merely a word which which we might very
well have no equivalent for in English
so there are words that I talk about in
the book like the word caught up is the
most famous one of these thought up
which means something like musical
ecstasy the feeling of musical ecstasy
which is shared between a performer and
an audience and it becomes a very
important word for discussing notions of
meter and music in modern modernist
poetry versus more traditional poetry so
how to translate table is is a question
I look at very briefly but I think in
the end if commentary is also doing the
work of translation I think you know
that's just your job right right okay
good so what would you like your reader
to take away from your book well I would
like them to as I was saying you know
I'd like them to take away the idea that
this is a an immensely interesting rich
corpus of poetry that probably most
American readers are unfamiliar with I
also hope that you know those who are
interested in in poetry generally
speaking by looking at this particular
movement might learn to look at the the
texts and verse that they are more
familiar with with new eyes mm-hmm okay
wonderful
thank you
so much for being here with us today and
sharing your work it was a pleasure for
more information about Professor
Cresswell and his research please visit
our website at macmillan report yale.edu
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Centre for
International and area studies at you
you